so we're given a 30-60-90 triangle here
we want to find this side to this side
and they're giving us this side here
nine I'm going to show you the
proportion method the two triangles that
you want to memorize are the 30-60-90
and the 45-45-90 but the key thing to
remember is that the side across from
the 30-degree angle this is the short
leg the site is one the one across from
the 60-degree angle this is the longer
leg we call that square root of three
and they want to cross in the 90 degree
angle that's the hypotenuse that's the
two side so what you can do now is if
you look at these two triangles what we
can do is we can form a proportion so
I'll say I want to solve for side X here
I can say X is two nine as one is two
square root of three so I'm comparing
the short leg to the long leg short leg
to the long leg those ratios are going
to be the same so now all we have to do
is cross multiply across the diagonal
divide by square root of 3 to get X by
itself and then we don't want the square
root of 3 in the denominator so we have
to rationalize by multiplying by square
root of 3 over square root of 3 so this
comes out to 9 square root of 3 divided
by square root of 9 which is just 3 and
the 9 and the 3 we can reduce to just 3
square root of 3 now if we wanted to
find Y the hypotenuse here we can do the
exact same thing we could say 9 is 2 y
as square root of 3 is 2 2 so there we
go and all we have to do is cross
multiply across the diagonals and we got
it so 18 equals square root of 3y divide
both sides by square root of 3 and then
you can rationalize from there let's
look at the 45-45-90 triangle now so the
one you want to know for the 45-45-90 is
the 1 1 square root of 2 the two sides
that make up the right angle these sides
are both 1 the one across from the right
angle that's the hypotenuse that's the
square root of 2 side same idea that
we're gonna make a proportion I'm going
to say 10 is 2y as square root of 2 is 2
1 and then all I have to do is cross
multiply on the diagonals and you can
see we have square root of 2 times y
equals 10
divide both sides by square root of 2
and you have y equals 10 over root 2 and
then will rationalize I multiplied by
square root of 2 over square root of 2
we get 10 square root of 2 over square
root 2 times square root of 2 is square
root of 4 which is 2 and the 10 and the
2 we can reduce to 5 square root of 2
now what's interesting in the 45-45-90
triangle is that these two sides are
congruent so if you know this is 5 or 2
you also know that this is 5 root 2 if
you want to see a quicker way to work
with 30 60 90 and 45-45-90 triangles and
my preferred method check out the video
I did right over there and I'll see over
in that video
you